8) Let's talk about Lemmings
When you hear the word "lemmings" you probably think of two things:
This game, and some small animal that commits suicide by jumping off a cliff
if the population becomes too large.
For if you didn't know it yet, lemmings are real, cute and not suicidal.
The origin of this myth is a bit unclear but the video game probably has a lot of young people
convinced that lemmings conscientiously commit suicide - and enormously
frustrating to be micro-manageable and therefore deserving of mass eradication.
7) Daddly Longlegs
These wispy-looking things have the reputation of being the most poisonous of all spiders.
But they are also very common, so you might wonder why no more people die
Daddy-Longleg bites every year.
Like a good conspiracy, this myth hides its own traces by saying that
their canines are too small to pierce human skin.
You could count a point on team people except that this misconception has a triple blow
of error is:
1) Daddy Longlegs have no fangs
2) They do not produce poison
3) They are not even spiders
6) Ostriches
Let's take a look at the characteristics of these non-flying birds
They are up to 2.74 meters long, up to 154 kilos, aggressive, and have sharp beaks
long claws.
In fact, the ostrich is the most similar to a living velociraptor that you
ever see.
(At least until our genetic manupilation technologies get better, come on Dinoapocalypse!).
Anyway, with these facts in mind, if you decide to threaten an ostrich
Do you really think he will stick his head in the sand and wait to die?
No, of course not, if you're lucky he would run away at 64 k / m, and if not
then it's deadly accident time for you.
Ostriches have no reason to hide and certainly not in the stupidest way ever.
If they did, they would have survived as long as a certain other species of non-flying bird.
Speaking of non-flying birds,
5) Baby Birds
A mother bird would leave her baby as soon as you touch it, as one
human mother would abandon her baby if a bird touched it.
If you find a bird, and you can reach the nest, it is really good to see the beast
to stop back.
4) Goldfish memory
Goldfish have a memory longer than 3 or 7 seconds or
no matter how long people say.
In fact, they can be trained and will remember for months. What's more
then what can be said of some people.
By the way, goldfish are also delicious.
3) Dog view
Poor dogs, living in their pathetic, monochrome world.
Except that is not the case. Dogs see colors but not in our way.
Most people see 3 primary colors, red, blue and green, but dogs only see 2:
They can see blue, but they cannot distinguish the rest of the color spectrum.
What they don't care until you buy a red toy for them and throw it in the green grass,
and then finds them stupid because they can't find it.
It is easy for you because your ancestors have spent millions of years picking
of red objects against a green background and are therefore quite good at it. Unless they don't
they could and they would die - but dog eyes are not monkey eyes and for your dog
holds, if it's not blue, it's all the same.
So next time in the pet store, get a blue toy for Rover.
And when we talk about watching, let's talk about:
2) Bats
Which, if you have looked at them, it should be immediately clear that they are not blind
are because they look at you - with their eyes - that they use to.
see.
They do have something better with an extra sense called echolocation for it
ensures that they can see in the dark, something that you cannot.
So from the perspective of a bat you are blind.
1) You can cook a frog to death if you do it very slowly.
This is true ... sort of.
Friedrich Goltz, demonstrated that a frog will happily sit in a boiling pot
water as long as the temperature rises slowly enough.
However, 1 of the striking facts is often forgotten in the Goltz story
namely that he took their brains out before he put them in the pot.
Which gives the frog a disadvantage.
Goltz also showed that if you don't lobotomize the frog first (brain out) he will
then just stand out.
It seems logical - but do not try this at home - that removing the brain from which animal
therefore, survival instances are properly prevented.
And it makes them more sensitive to common misconceptions